our top story the secrets of Islamic
state and its members revealed I think
this is the biggest security breach for
a terror organization in history tonight
the details of what one intelligence
expert told us could be the biggest
breakthrough in years
you've got to realize what you're
exposing what exposing is pure evil a
source from inside the network tells us
the documents could bring Islamic state
to its knees it's never happened before
and I was pretty certain after this
it'll never happen again
[Music]
the first indication that we had
something different was from our
producer Mahmoud who said we're being
told there's paperwork that identifies
Islamic state fighters but particularly
foreigners it was when I received a
message from someone willing to keep his
Syria
he has relations with people instead is
in Raqqa they sent him thousands of
files
I remember my move saying to me Stewart
it'd be very difficult for people to
make this up because there's just huge
amounts of these files there are
thousands and thousands so I said let's
sort of go and have a look
we are working out of ascetical bertha
which is a turkish city with a huge Arab
population
[Music]
if the Islamic state members were able
to escape from Syria they were actually
often visiting family or friends in Urfa
it felt eerie and I knew at that point
it was quite a dangerous place to be
because that's where a lot of fighters
are going in and out this area
yeah we stick out like a sore thumb in
eastern Turkey there aren't really many
foreigners who arrive the Secret Service
of Turkey which is huge would know
exactly where we were
we spent huge amounts of time walking
through markets looking at dates and
peppers and garlic and all the rest of
it we've pretty much got rid of the
potential of being watched and then it
was literally a case of waiting for them
say right now's the time to come
so you go through those areas and then
find yourself in the upper story of a
four or five floor apartment block we're
going to meet a defector from Islamic
state who apparently is going to hand
over files that might be the key to
breaking Islamic state
it was always extremely tense he's a
dangerous guy
it's a dangerous location and we don't
know if it's gonna work when you look
back it seems fairly relaxed everyone
sitting down and we're all going on fine
but actually you know we had to put our
security guys outside on the street if
anything changed very quickly we would
have to be prepared to move very fast
there was a concern we didn't know who
we were meeting you've come from Raqqa
why have you come to Turkey and then we
talked a lot about the importance of the
documents is this information so
important that it could actually destroy
it - Charla he's a lot like to be this
part I first of all the more I keep I
thought we'd be getting some files I did
not expect to get every single Isis
recruit
I mean it was just quite simply a USB
stick just like you'd find in a WI
Smith's anywhere the information on this
could bring down the entire network not
just in Iraq and Syria but across the
world put it into the Mac and opened up
my Finder window and no joke Arabic name
Arabic name every name wherever they
came from if they joined up it's on here
Adam tells me he goes there's if there's
just thousands of thousands and
thousands of files here well it was it
was me answer to his mouth just went to
the ground because it was if you were
there you just take one look at it and
you knows it was real it was what it
said any jurist who came to Syria from
the beginning of Islamic state he had to
give full information about himself his
passport his phone number everything it
named people who effectively members of
a proscribed organization who could
potentially be planning terror attacks
in the UK or or elsewhere in the world
but it also gave information about them
named their mothers and gave skills
their names their nationalities their
phone numbers the sponsors
it would be like the HR files of any
organization and to have that kind of
information is just I would say
unprecedented I was astonished I didn't
expect that I said to my food I need
something an idea of whether it's true
or not
just scroll down till you find a British
name and tell me who it is
so he started really said this guy is
from China zero this guy is from Morocco
and this guy's from Uzbekistan ah this
is the British guy and I said who is it
he said oh there's a guy called janae
the same I said you're kidding me he
said why Stu I don't know this guy and I
said yeah he's he's quite famous Junaid
Hussain was the head of the social media
arm of Islamic state which became his
huge brilliantly well organized
propaganda section so once we've done
all that and mashed it all up we just
thought we're onto a winner here there's
no way there's no way in a million years
this isn't genuine there has never been
a leak from an active terror
organization on a scale even remotely
like this an unprecedented cache of
information that could destroy Islamic
states fighting infrastructure but also
I was worried was it too good to be true
calling somebody a terrorist is about
the most defamatory allegation you can
make
even if you're confident that something
is genuine and you're confident that
these documents really are effectively
the HR files for Isis then we have to be
able to prove it because it's no good
they can be real but if we can't prove
it somebody named in them could still
potentially sue us we were worried that
we could be naming people that had
nothing to do with it I mean so much so
that you could close the company if you
were that wrong
when a media organization makes a big
mistake that's the thing that makes a
noise that's the thing that people
remember a lot of the names are
well-known to us
abdel bari a 26 year old from london
entered in 2013 the way we did it and
this was Matt McKenzie who made us do it
was to actually say we can identify the
know and jihadis that is the only way
around it we can do them known ones and
by and large they're dead
we only identified known associates of
Isis people that were known to have
trained with Isis and actually who were
reported to have been killed because
ultimately that couldn't possibly be
confused with somebody else and we had
come from Cardin who also entered in
2013 so it was a sort of disappointing
way to break the story with a load of
names everyone knew but what it did was
pretty much tell everyone in the world
but we know an awful lot more our top
story the secrets of Islamic state and
its members revealed then it went
absolutely crazy the documents could
bring Islamic states to its knees it's
50-plus news organizations each were
ringing me within minutes of our our
first piece go into air and I remember
one of the first analysts came on and
said the files are fake
and by heart
absolutely son and they said the
typeface that they're using was
different and the flag was different on
the paperwork and I I remember sort of
like reading that and sort of I think I
lay it I told sat on the floor until
well that's it then
I'm finished we had no reason to think
they were anything other than genuine
but even then when somebody says we'll
hold on they're not real because of a B
and C there's a doubt yeah I felt
physically sick I went from having the
best scoop to the biggest embarrassment
there has ever been my reputation would
be gone forever
I remember I was picking up the phone I
could hardly stop my hand shaking I was
just shaking shaking saying I've got to
make this call and I have to make this
call to the only person who can possibly
I can trust on this because I can't I
don't know anyone else who can help me
with this
and that was my clue and he said done
Stuart
they changed the flag and the typeface
they changed it's true it's really these
files are simply the best intelligence
that's ever existed about Islamic state
our analysis of the files reveal that
jihadists have made their way to Syria
from at least 51 nations across the
globe well some breaking news for you
just in that Denmark has arrested four
suspects guns and ammunition have been
found by police in Denmark following the
arrest of four suspected Islamic state
terrorists arrests were made across
Europe really really quickly very soon
same thing was happening in the UK they
could arrest people and hold them for
suspicion of being members of Islamic
state
mahmud Abdullah became the first person
to be convicted for his involvement in
being a member of Islamist state he came
from Manchester he was part of a
Manchester cell there is a direct link
to the Manchester bombings he was on the
forms he had listed himself as wanted to
be a sniper for Islamic state he had
clearly been trained that was very much
a test case to determine whether or not
the is files actually had evidential
value what was interesting about the
Crown Prosecution Services position on
this was that they wanted to secure a
conviction based on membership of the
files signing up to the files means you
were you were a member of a proscribed
organisation which is a terrorist group
and you will go to prison this
information helped to know is from the
site I think they helped to collapse
this organisation to know their
commanders the sponsors this network in
Syria and in other countries
you know the exposure that it got when
we got back here and actually what came
out of it you know what people getting
arrested and you've got to realize what
you're exposing what you exposing is
pure evil it was more important than
just being the first to break this story
it's part of the DNA of being a
journalist of course but it was actually
we have to do justice to these files as
best we can because they are absolutely
important and the names on here are
people who have carried out are carrying
out tactical or are about to carry out
attacks
anyone on those files will go to prison
if they're caught
[Music]